hey guys today I'm going to be doing a
tutorial and after HD tutorial this
one's gonna be about how to get the
Windows Vista Start menu and all the
features that I use in my videos working
on Windows XP so first you want to open
up a web browser is some freeware that I
found online and I type in this to start
okay and the first one that crash
alright reading hopefully you won't have
to hopefully one huh I won't have to use
the zoom so you guys can see this in HD
they start Google search it the first
link you'll have is a ly soft link and
click on that and they'll have three
wafer they'll have three actual links
that you can download here the first one
they start which is the Vista Start menu
the second one is the orb which this
start button that glows when you hover
over it and the last one is the Explorer
which is the Windows Vista Explorer and
all these features etc telling you about
your computer down here so what I was
suggesting you guys do is click on good
start and it's gonna bring up that you
can use the Vista Start menu SP here it
is it looks just like mine all the same
features you type in say WI n you'll get
all your results for programs files even
communications so if I type in WN I'll
get my programs favorites history files
and communications like emails I've
gotten with that in it and if I still
don't see it here I can search
everywhere it search the internet so you
click the download button right there
obviously I don't need it because well I
have it but you're going to get other
features that I use my videos so say
ideas that's on your stamp and search
magnifier the first result that will
come up will be a program called
magnifier and that's so I have to do so
if you download this if you're using
Windows XP and you like what you see in
my videos then go ahead and download
that and you'll be that much faster I'd
opening
rooms etcetera so if you like these
video tutorials come peace